after the release of 1.79 straight into
farming for that sweet classified gear
we have a real life and bad luck held me
back from acquiring most of the gear
owes after so this build is for my
fellow casual games there are no 5 or 6
piece sets in this build not because I
didn't want them that because I just
couldn't find them but I figure there's
probably quite a number of people in the
same position it's not that we can't
keep looking for this gear it's just
that the drop rate is exceptionally low
outside of the global event I'm calling
this the poor man's sniper build I was
using an acronym but I decided it didn't
really look quite right at first this
was intended as a super high DPS build
to support the more tanky builds in your
team but when the damage numbers started
consistently hitting over the 1 million
mark started working out pretty fun as a
solo build to almost every enemy is
taken down in 1 or 2 shots I've been
quite enjoying running around as a
one-shot sniper and I've had success in
all PvE content solo or in a team I've
even used it successfully in a couple of
PvP situations though I wouldn't
recommend this initially I was building
a stock standard did I build but it felt
a bit cheesy and I got bored of it quick
plus I hate the fact your headshots mean
nothing so I've been working on a bit of
a hybrid build where focuses put on both
headshot damage and critical hit damage
I haven't had a chance to test out the
full build that I had in mind because I
couldn't find the gear but I see this is
a much easier to achieve alternative
while I keep farming this won't get you
the high damage numbers arse planning
that you'll consistently hit for up to
one to one-and-a-half million points
that will very quickly drop whatever's
coming at you
however unlike did I if you can't land
your headshots you'll struggle to
achieve these numbers as with all of my
build videos I'll be trying to keep this
as clear and concise as possible I will
never state that you need to match
everything I've added to the build and
it's did the idea as few days as a
starting point or a template for your
own built change things up and
personalize it for your style of play
this build consists of two-piece Deadeye
2-piece century a wreckless chest and
the ninja bike messenger bag the idea is
to stack as much into firearms headshot
damage and critical hood damage as
possible full glass cannon
all gear pieces have been rolled into
firearms and all made retribution tis
critical hit damage in the first
instance or skill power or skill haste
depending on the piece all mods should
be fire us with skill haste as the
attribute applying the above that should
leave you with around nine to ten
thousand firearms and two hundred twenty
percent plus headshot damage also you
should be aiming for a minimum of one
hundred and ten percent critical hit
damage the equipped skills are tactical
scanner and booster shot tactical
scanner for an increase in critical hit
damage and booster shot for a further
increase in damage having the highest
skill haste would allow you to have
these running most of the time the two
talents that I would call a must are
critical save and struck back to help
get you out of those sticky situations
when your health gets low the other two
slots are optional here I'm using
technical advance and precision for even
more damage the primary weapon I'm using
is the custom m-44 here's where things
start to go a little bit different from
the standard did I built nothing up
until this point has been placing into
critical hit charts so one of the skills
on this weapon is an absolute
requirement of this build disciplined
killing a target will make your next
shot with the weapon an automatic
critical hit so of this triggered which
is reasonably easy with the bolt-action
sniper and landing constant headshots
you'll turn this gun into a one-shot
killing machine as you can see I haven't
managed to find the best weapon for this
year but the perfect gun would be a
bolt-action sniper with high base
headshot damage with disciplined brutal
and deadly the secondary weapon is
really up to you I'd recommend to close
the combat weapon like a shotgun or less
mg for anything that manages to rush you
down but if you're confident with you
snipe you may choose to use instead a
higher rate of fire marksman rifle here
I'm using the showstopper shotgun one
because shotguns can nicely take
advantage of the headshot bonus damage
and - it's just really fun to use at the
end of this video I've included a cheat
sheet or a quick reference guide that
sums up this build and everything I've
covered check it out and see what you
think I'll leave you with a little bit
of gameplay now but if you'd like to see
more of this type of content from us
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment below thanks
[Music]
fine
[Applause]
warning additional hostiles in BAM
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]